also this morning we think about all of
these survivors from one october and one
of the ways they work to heal
and learn to reclaim their bodies is by
getting tattoos to cover the scars both
physical and emotional as well our
bianca holman is live now for us with
more on that story good morning bianca
good morning alex you know so many and
several events are happening around the
valley
of to honor the victims of one october
and also the survivors such as
for example this blood drive that's
happening here at the las vegas ballpark
in addition to that we've also learned
about the healing tattoo event
this event of course allowing survivors
and first responders to get
tattoos in honor of the victims or
inspirational messages for themselves
now here's a little bit more information
about it
many survivors admit they're still
heavily affected by the tragedy
the healing inc program is stepping in
to make a difference
they say they're using tattoos as a
powerful force for good
some survivors choosing to honor those
lost others tattooing themselves with
inspiration
we've had people come to us throughout
the years you've changed my life
you've saved my life there are people
who come to the healing
team and said we were constant i was
contemplating suicide or
my quality of life i wasn't leaving my
house
because of my scars or whatever and now
i have this beautiful tattoo and i'm
proud i walk out and i'm like look at me
as a tattooer watching that
transformation is just something
unbelievable and that's why we get such
a big outpour
from artists
now there were over a hundred people
that put an application to be a part of
this program but
the healing art project they tattooed
about 23 people and they have 17 artists
some of them local some of them from out
of state but there were several first
responders that received tattoos
and some of those first responders again
were there at the festival as civilians
and then
quickly jumped into action the night of
the tragedy